「量子情報と計算の理解」へようこそ。私はJohn Watusで、IBMの教育担当テクニカルディレクターだ。
Quantum。これはシリーズの第10回目のレッスンで、第3ユニットの第2回目のレッスンだ。第3ユニットは量子情報の一般的な
定式化についてで、このレッスンのテーマはチャネルだ。チャネルとは、量子情報を保持する
システムの変化を表すものだ。これにはunitary Gateや量子circuitによって行われるような有用な操作と、
できれば避けたいノイズのような変化が含まれる。測定もチャネルとして記述でき、
それは次のレッスンで取り上げる。「チャネル」という言葉は
情報理論から来ていて、情報理論はノイズのある通信
チャネルの情報伝達容量などを研究する分野だ。チャネルについて考えるとき、私たちは抽象的に通信
チャネルを考えている。複雑な計算を通信チャネルとして考えるのは少し奇妙に思えるかもしれないが、私たちには
何らかの形で情報を変化させるプロセスという一般的な概念を指す言葉が必要だ。良くも悪くも、「チャネル」という言葉が
定着した。これは間違いなく、情報理論の巨大な影響、特に
1940年代のClaude Shannonの研究が量子情報と計算に与えた影響によるところが大きい。これがレッスンの概要だ。
まず基礎から始める。チャネルとは何かの定義と、簡略化された定式化でのunitary操作が
量子情報においてチャネルとしてどのように記述されるかを扱う。また、チャネルの凸結合もチャネルであるという事実についても話す。もし
この凸性の概念がなぜ何度も登場するのか疑問に思っているなら、それは凸性が量子情報の理論において
根本的に重要な数学的概念だからだ。また、チャネルの具体例、特にqubit channelも見ていく。それは
レッスンの残りの部分を通して何度も登場する。レッスンの第2部では、チャネルを表現できる3つの異なる方法について話す。
数学的には特に、Stinespring表現、Kraus表現、Choi
表現について話す。これらはこれらの異なる表現の発展に重要な業績を残した3人にちなんで名付けられている。そして第3の
最終部では、これら3つの表現が実際に同値であることを証明する数学的な証明と、それらが
すべてチャネルの定義を正しく特徴付けるという事実を議論する。私の意見では本当にクールな数学的証明で、これらの異なる
表現、それらの関係、そして一般的にどのように機能するかについての明確さが増すことを期待している。では基礎から始めて、
「チャネルとは何か」という問いに答えよう。すでにレッスンの冒頭で示唆したように、チャネルは変化を記述する。
具体的には、量子情報を保持するシステムにおける離散時間的な変化だ。ここで離散時間の
変化とは、単に2つの異なる時点の間に生じる変化のことで、
無限小の時間間隔にわたって考えるような連続的なプロセスとは対照的だ。チャネルには、量子Gateや circuitによって行われる
unitary操作のような有用な操作と、ノイズによる変化が含まれる。しかし、
このレッスンの目的のためには、ほとんどの場合チャネルを抽象的な数学的概念として考えることになり、
何が有用で何がそうでないかを区別する特段の必要性はない。チャネルの典型的な名前には、大文字のギリシャ文字のΦ、
Ψ、Λなどがあり、特定のチャネルを指すために異なる文字を使う。密度行列ρで記述される状態にあるシステムがあって、
そのシステムにchannel Φを適用するという単純な状況では、
結果は密度行列Φ(ρ)で記述される状態のシステムだ。つまり、与えられた
channel Φを、特定のサイズの密度行列、換言すれば
このチャネルを適用する特定のシステムの密度行列に適用できる関数として考えている。チャネルが有効なチャネルと見なされるためには、満たすべき
要件がいくつかある。第一に、チャネルは線形写像だ。これは、量子状態ベクトルへの操作が必然的に線形である
量子情報の簡略化された定式化の状況と完全に類似している。また、
確率的操作が線形である古典情報の標準的な定式化とも類似している。本当に望むなら、この線形性の基本的な
要件に疑問を呈することもできるが、確率論と
密度行列による量子状態の表現の両方と整合性のある理論を求めるなら、選択の余地はなく、チャネルが線形であることを受け入れるしかない。
第二の要件は、チャネルが密度行列を密度行列に変換するということだ。これは完全に理にかなっている。なぜなら、
システムの状態を密度行列で表現することを選び、何らかの状態にあるシステムにチャネルを適用するなら、結果は有効な状態でなければならず、したがって
密度行列で表現される必要があるからだ。ただし、ここで非常に重要な点を付け加えなければならない。この要件は
孤立したシステムにチャネルを適用する場合だけでなく、
密度行列で記述された状態を持つ複合システムがあって、そのシステムの一部だけにチャネルを適用する
場合にも真でなければならない。これらがチャネルに課す要件で、それらは
量子情報の簡略化された定式化と古典情報の標準的な定式化の両方における操作の要件と非常に類似していることがわかる。
量子情報の簡略化された定式化では、操作はunitary行列で表現される。なぜなら、それらは
与えられたシステムに対して量子状態ベクトルを常に量子状態ベクトルに変換する線形写像に正確に対応するからだ。
同様に、確率的操作は確率行列（stochastic matrices）で表現される。それらが
確率ベクトルを常に確率ベクトルに変換するものだからだ。ここでは密度行列を扱っており、
複合システムに関するこの追加要件があるが、これは量子状態ベクトルには
必要ではないことがわかる。確率ベクトルについても同様で、それ以外は要件は類似しており、ある意味で密度行列による
量子状態の表現の選択によって強制されるものだ。ここにはチャネルについてのさらなる詳細があり、レッスン全体を通して
チャネルの入力システムと出力システムについてどのように考えるかの規約と、
チャネルが常に密度行列を密度行列に変換するという要件についてのより詳しい説明が含まれる。まず、すべてのチャネルは
入力システムと出力システムを持つと仮定する。これらのシステムは好きな名前を付けられるが、このレッスン全体を通して
入力システムをXと呼び、出力システムをYと呼ぶことにする。概念的に言えば、チャネルは
入力システムを出力システムに変換するので、入力と出力のシステムが同時に共存することはない。
Xから始まり、チャネルが適用または実行されると、Xは状態が
チャネルに関連付けられた線形写像によって決定されるYに変換される。チャネルの入力と出力のシステムは同一である必要はなく、特に
古典的な状態の数が同じである必要もない。ただし、入力と出力のシステムが実際に同じシステムである、つまり
つまりxはyと等しいということで、その場合はfiがシステムの状態を変えていると単純に考えるわけだ。実際、これは
非常によくある状況だ。ただ、この可能性は最初の箇条書きと矛盾しない。つまり、入力と
出力のシステムが同時に別々のシステムとして存在することは決してないという意味でだ。いずれにせよ、
このレッスンの目的のために、入力と出力のシステムをそれぞれXとYという別の文字で表すのが便利だ
整理しやすくするためだ。では、channelが常にdensity
matrixを変換するという要件についてもう少し詳しく見ていこう
density matrixへと変換するという要件だ。ここで、新しいシステムZを導入するとしよう。
この新しいシステムの古典的な状態集合にgammaという名前をつける。ここで、新しい複合システムZXを構成することを想像してほしい
この新しいシステムとchannel fiの入力システムXとで構成されるものだ。そしてこの複合システムが
density matrix rowで記述される状態にあると仮定する。これはこのペアの任意のquantum状態でいい。どんな状態であれ、
density matrix rowを画面に表示された形式で表現することは常に可能だ。AとBの両方が
古典的な状態集合gammaの範囲にあり、各row ABはXの古典的な状態集合に対応する行と列を持つ何らかのmatrixだ
この時点でその古典的な状態集合に名前をつける必要はない。明確にしておくと、各row ABは必ずしも単独の
density matrixではないが、matrix row全体は必ずdensity matrixになる。channel 5をシステムXに適用すると、
Xはyに変換され、ペアZYが残る。fiをXだけに実行した後のこのペアの状態を決定する方法は、
各matrix row aに対して線形写像fiを評価することだ
別の言い方をすると、写像fiとgammaに対応する行と列を持つ正方matrixに対する恒等写像のtensor productを取るということだ
これは新しいシステムZに何もしないことに対応する。だが、これは等価な
表現であり、この形式の写像のtensor productについての詳細に踏み込む必要はない。これらは
ベクトルやmatrixに対して機能するのと類似した、かなり直感的な方法で機能する。視覚的に考える一つの方法は
block matrixで考えることだ。古典的な状態集合gammaがある正の整数Mに対して
0からN-1までの整数から成るという単純化した仮定をすると、これを全部書き下すのが簡単になる
ここに示したように。改めて述べると、fiが有効なchannelであるための要件として、このプロセスから常にdensity
matrixを得なければならない。そしてこれは、システムZの選択に関わらず、
density matrixである限りrowの選択に関わらず成立しなければならない。かなり厳しい要件に思えるかもしれないし、
確認するのが非常に難しそうにも見えるかもしれない。しかしレッスンの最後までには、実はそれほど厳しいわけでも
確認が難しいわけでもないことがわかる。特に、この条件に対する優れた数学的な特徴付けがある
それらはレッスンで後ほど説明するさまざまな表現と結びついている。では、channelの例をいくつか見ていこう
unitary channelと呼ばれるカテゴリのchannelから始めよう。簡単に言えば、これらはunitary
演算だ。channelとして見たquantum informationの単純化した定式化と同様だ。正確には、UがシステムX上のunitary
演算を表すunitary matrixだとしよう。quantum informationの単純化した定式化では、
与えられたquantum state vectorにこのmatrixを掛けて、その演算がquantum stateに与える作用を決定する。
density matrixに対してはどう機能するかというと、density matrixの左にUを掛け、右にU
daggerを掛ける。数学的にはこの演算をmatrix Uによる共役と呼ぶ。これはKSI
brasaiがquantum state vector sで表される状態を記述するdensity matrixであることと一致しており、
特にquantum state vector KiにUを実行すると U * Ki が得られ、そのdensity matrix表現は
そのvectorとその複素共役転置の積、つまり U * Ki * brasai * U
daggerで与えられる。U * Kiの共役転置を評価するとき、このようにchannelが定義されていることは
pure stateに対して意味をなし、これを線形性と組み合わせることで、density matrixに対しても一般的に意味をなすことがわかる
すべてのdensity matrixはpure stateの凸結合として表現できるからだ。この
定義は、unitary演算uの任意の選択に対して常に有効なchannelを与える。特に、このように
unitary matrixで共役を取ってもmatrixのトレースは変わらないし、任意の半正定値
matrixを任意のmatrixで共役を取っても別の半正定値matrixが得られる。これは
半正定値matrixの定義から直接導くのはかなり簡単だ。つまりdensity matrixは常にdensity
matrixに写される。そしてこれは、任意のサイズの恒等matrixとtensorしても成立する。これは
複合システムの一部だけにこのchannelを適用することと等価だ。unitary channelの非常に単純な例を挙げよう。
U自体を恒等matrixとしよう。これは明らかに有効なchannelで、恒等channelと呼ばれる。
何もしないことは確かに線形演算であり、density matrixから始めて何もしなければ、それは
依然としてdensity matrixだ。つまりこれは有効なchannelだ。このchannelを表すのにいろんな記号が使われる
恒等matrixに使うのと全く同じ記号を使うこともあり、少し混乱することもあるが、一般的には問題ない。ここでは
混乱を避けるため、identityの略でIDという文字を使う。この表記もよく使われる。非常に
つまらないchannelに思えるかもしれないが、情報伝送の文脈では実際には完璧なchannelで、
受信者が送信者の送ったものをそのまま受け取る。その文脈では通常それが最も望まれることだ。channelの例を多数得る別の方法は
channelの凸結合を取ること、言い換えれば平均を取ることだ
そしてそれができるということはchannelの重要な側面だ。詳しく説明するために、2つのchannel F0と51から始めよう。
さらに0と1の間の実数Pも用意する。明確にしておくと、これら2つのchannelは
同じ入力システムXと同じ出力システムYを持つと仮定している。では、確率pで最初のchannel F0を
適用し、そうでなければ残りの確率1-PでF0を適用すると決めた場合に何が起きるか考えよう
2番目のchannel F1だ。例えば、その確率でランダムにbitを選び、このランダムなbitを使って
どのchannelを適用するか決めるとしよう。こうすることで、サイと呼ぶかもしれない新しいchannelを実質的に適用していることになる
それは最初の2つのchannelの凸結合で与えられ、画面に書かれているように表現できる
ところで、このように線形写像の線形結合を常に取ることができる。そして線形
線形写像の組み合わせが与えられた入力に対してどう定義されるかというと、出力の同じ線形結合を取るだけだ
それは些細なことに見えるかもしれないが、意味は通る――この仮想的なシナリオから得られる出力は単純に
元の2つのチャネルから得られる出力の加重平均だ。それでも、これは新しいチャネルであり
φ0とφ1が実際に有効なチャネルであれば、この新しい写像も確実に有効なチャネルになる。別の言い方をすると
数学的な言葉では、与えられた入力系から与えられた出力系へのすべてのチャネルの集合は
凸であり、それはチャネルの重要な数学的性質だ。より一般的にも同様のことができて、M個のチャネルφ0からfm-1があるとすると
各チャネルの確率を示す確率ベクトルとともに、チャネルを適切に平均することで新しいチャネルが得られる。つまり
ある意味、これは新しいチャネルの尽きない源だ。例えば、いわゆる混合ユニタリチャネルのクラスは
ユニタリチャネルの凸結合を取ることで得られる。つまり、M個のユニタリ行列u0からum-1があって
すべて同じサイズで確率ベクトルとともにある場合、チャネルの加重平均を取ると
個々のユニタリ行列に対応するものは画面に示されている通りで、チャネルが得られる。そして
このように書けるチャネルを混合ユニタリチャネルと呼ぶ。すべてのチャネルが混合ユニタリチャネルというわけではなく、
この方法ですべてのチャネルを得られるわけではないが、よく登場する。次は特定のいくつかの
チャネルの例を見ていく。これらはすべて1つのqubitから1つのqubitへのチャネルの例で、qubit
チャネルと略される。最初のものはqubitリセットチャネルと呼ばれ、このチャネルはqubitを
ゼロ状態にリセットする。ここでこのチャネルを表すのにギリシャ大文字のΛを使い、このチャネルが何をするか覚える方法は
ブロッホ球について考えることだ。大文字のΛは上向きの矢印のように見え、ゼロ状態はブロッホ球の頂点にあるので、まるで
出力の位置を指しているかのようだ。数学的な言葉での定義は、Λ(ρ)はρのトレースとket0 bra0の積であり
任意の密度行列ρに対して評価すると、密度行列としてゼロ状態が得られる。なぜ
トレースが必要なのか疑問に思うのは自然だ――前にあるρのトレースなしに単純にΛ(ρ)をket0 bra0と定義できないのか
という問いへの答えはノーだ。チャネルは線形写像でなければならず、ρのトレースを取り除いたら線形でなくなる。また、
チャネルが非密度行列の入力に対して線形写像としてどう機能するかを知る必要がある場合があることも覚えておいてほしい。例えば
以前見たように、チャネルを複合系に適用するときに何をするかを知りたければ
そのチャネルをより大きなブロック行列の個々のブロックに対して評価する必要があり、ブロック行列全体は
密度行列であっても、個々のブロックは一般的にそうではない。だから、このチャネルを
複合系の一部だけに適用した場合に何をするか、より具体的には2つのqubitのうちの1つに適用した場合に何をするかを正確に見てみよう
ebitを形成する場合だ。正確には、AとBがqubitのペアとしてΦ+ベル状態にあるとし、Λを
最初のqubit Aに適用するとしよう。何が起きるかを把握するために、まずΦ+状態を密度行列として表し
この例のためにディラック記法を使ってみよう。これがΦ+状態を量子状態ベクトルとして表したもので、これが
このベクトルをその共役転置に掛けてすべて展開したものだ。それからチャネルを最初のqubitに適用して得られるものを評価できる
Λを最初のqubitに適用したものと、各項を評価して得られるものがここにある。ket0 bra0のトレースは1で
ket1 bra1のトレースも同様に1だ。だからその2つの場合、チャネルの出力はket0 bra0になり、それが
答えの2つの項を説明している。一方、ket0 bra1のトレースはゼロで、ket1 bra0のトレースも同様だ
だからその2つの項はゼロに評価され、答えに何も寄与しない。少し
整理すると、得られるのはAである最初のqubitのゼロ状態と、
Bである2番目のqubitの完全混合状態だ。特に、Bのプラス状態は得られなかったことに注目してほしい――密度行列について何も知らずに
量子状態ベクトル表現だけを見ていたなら、必ずしも悪い推測ではなかっただろうが、
このチャネルはそうは機能しない。そして、そのように機能できるチャネルは存在しない。チャネルΛはqubitリセットチャネルと呼ばれるが、
実際の動作はむしろ入力qubitをゴミ箱に捨てて、ゼロ状態の新鮮なqubitに置き換えるようなものだ。しかしこれは実際には
常にゼロ状態を出力する唯一のqubitチャネルだ。qubitチャネルの別の例として
完全デフェージングチャネルがある。これはΔで表され、その動作は2×2行列の対角
成分はそのままにして、非対角成分をゼロにする。Δはラテンアルファベットのdに相当するギリシャ文字で、
dはdiagonal（対角）の略だ。だからそれがこのチャネルの動作を覚える1つの方法だ。
代わりにこのチャネルをディラック記法で表すこともでき、画面に示されている通りだ。明確にするために、出力は
常に2×2行列なので、特に2つのゼロ出力はすべてゼロの2×2行列を指す。これは
よく行うことで、このシリーズで以前見たことがある。記号ゼロは一般的に、スカラーでもベクトルでも行列でも何であれ
話している対象の零元を意味するためにやや曖昧に使われる。qubitリセットチャネルで以前やったのと同じことをして
このチャネルをebitの半分に適用するとどうなるか見てみよう。設定は同じなので省略する
結果は画面に示された状態で、本質的に共有ランダムビットだ。つまり
このチャネルは基本的にebitを完全に相関した古典的なランダムビットのペアに変換した
これはこのチャネルのより一般的な解釈と一致している。密度行列の非対角成分をゼロにすることで、実質的に
密度行列から量子的な要素を取り除き、古典的な確率状態を表す対角密度行列が残る
別の考え方は、このチャネルはビットを伝送する完全無雑音の古典チャネルを表しているということだ
つまり、ゼロ状態か1状態、またはその2つの凸結合をチャネルに入れると、その状態は変化せずに出てくる。しかし、
プラス状態のような量子状態を入れようとすると、チャネルがその状態を標準基底測定で測定して
古典的な結果を伝送するかのようになる。qubitチャネルの最後の例は完全デポラライジングチャネルだ。
このチャネルは常に完全混合状態を出力する。だからある意味でqubitリセットに似ているが
初期化されたqubitではなく、あまり役に立たない完全混合状態が出てくる。このチャネルについて自然な考え方は
極端な形のノイズを表しているということで、qubitチャネルに関する限り
これ以上ノイズが多くなることはない。このチャネルが何をするか覚えるための良い語呂合わせはないが、Ωはギリシャ文字の最後の
文字で、すべての終わりと関連付けられることがあり、おそらくこれはそのことを表しているのかもしれない
最終的にはすべてのqubitに影響を与える——ノイズという観点では非常に極端だが、一つできることは凸
このChannelと恒等Channelの組み合わせを考えることだ。完全な
脱分極に対して小さな確率Epsilonを設定する。これはより穏やかなノイズの形式で、与えられたqubitの状態はほとんどそのままだが、
完全に混合状態になるわずかな確率がある。幾何学的には、これをブロッホ球が中心に向かってわずかに収縮すると考えられる。
ちなみに、完全位相緩和Channelでも同様のことができる。例えばデコヒーレンスの過程をモデル化するためで、
何らかの過程を通じてわずかに古典的になっていく。というわけで、これがqubit channelの基本的な三例であり、
レッスンの残りを通じて主に例として立ち返ることになる。次にchannelの数学的な
表現について論じる。基本的な問いから始めよう。ベクトルからベクトルへの線形写像は常に
行列で表現できる——線形写像の作用が行列と
ベクトルの積で記述されるという馴染みのある形で。だがchannelは行列から行列への線形写像であって、ベクトルからベクトルではない。そこで
一般的にchannelを数学的にどう表現するか？特殊なchannelについては単純な公式がある場合もある。
すでに論じたqubit channelの例でもそうだった。しかし一般的には
そのような綺麗な公式が常にあるとは限らないから、実用的ではない。比較の観点として、量子情報の簡略化された
定式化では、量子状態ベクトルへの操作を表現するためにユニタリ行列を使う。
すべてのユニタリ行列は有効な操作を表し、すべての有効な操作はユニタリ行列として表現できる。つまり
本質的にこの問いが尋ねているのは、channelに対してどうやってこれを行うか、ということだ。その答えは、実際に複数の方法でchannelを表現できる、ということだ。
数学的な用語でchannelを表現する方法が複数あり、特に開発に重要な役割を果たした
三人の人物にちなんで名付けられた三つの異なる表現方法を論じる。Stinespring、Kraus、Choiだ。
まずこれらの異なる表現がどう機能するかを見て、レッスンの最後の部分で三つの表現の関係、特に
それらを変換する方法を見る。またこれらの表現がchannelに対する要件を正確に捉えていることも分かる。
つまり線形写像であること、そして複合系の
一部にだけ適用された場合でも、常に密度行列を密度行列に変換すること。まずはStinespring表現だ。Willam Forest Stinespring
は量子情報に取り組んでいた数学者ではなく、私が説明するStinespring表現は
ある意味で1950年代の作用素論に関する彼の研究の派生に過ぎない。しかしこの研究は確実に
量子channelが基づく数学の発展における重要な部分だった。このchannelの表現方法の背後にある考え方は、すべての
channelが特定の方法で実装できる、ということだ。今から説明する。まず、実装しようとしている
channelへの入力と初期化されたワークスペース系からなる複合系を構成する。次に
複合系にユニタリ操作を行い、最後に生成された複合系のうち
channelの出力に対応する部分だけを残すか出力し、残りを捨てる（トレースアウトする）。これを
図の形で表現すると分かりやすい。入力と
出力系が同じ特殊ケースから始めるのが最も簡単だ。この図はQuantum circuit図に似ているが、ワイヤーが
必ずしも単一のqubitではなく任意の系を表している。入力系Xがある状態
rowにあるとして、初期化されたワークスペース系Wを導入する。この図ではゼロがwの古典状態であると
仮定していて、k0を系の初期化された状態としているが、あるいは任意の純粋状態を
wの固定値として初期化された状態と見ることもできる。次にWXのペアにユニタリ操作を行い、
ワークスペース系をトレースアウトしてXを出力する。図中ではちなみに、電気工学のアース記号を
使ってWが捨てられることを示している。これは必ずしも慣例的ではなく、
Qiskitではそのような記号は使わない——興味のないqubitはただ無視するだけだ。要は、この議論の目的のために系を捨てていることを明確にする記号が欲しかっただけだ。
一般的に、入力と出力の系が必ずしも同じである必要はない。例えば、ガベージ
系Gとともに出力系yを持つことができ、
GはトレースアウトされるUがユニタリであるためには正方行列でなければならないので、
ペアgyが一緒にペアWXと同じ数の古典状態を持つという前提がある。例えばこれらの系が
qubitからなり、入力系Xが5つのqubit、Wが10個のqubitで構成されているとしよう。するとUは15個のqubitに対する
ユニタリ操作だ。そしてyが4つのqubitだけで構成されているとすると、gは11個のqubitで構成される。
あるいはこれらがqubitでない場合もある。重要なのはWXとgyが合わせて同じ数の
古典状態を持ち、ユニタリになれることだ。このようなchannelの記述はchannelのStinespring表現と呼ばれる。
このように記述できる任意の写像φが実際に有効なchannelであることを示すのは
かなり簡単だ。密度行列から始めて追加のワークスペース系を加えても、確かに
密度行列が得られる。ユニタリ操作を適用することで有効なChannelが得られることはすでに確認した。
複合系の密度行列があり、その一つの系をトレースアウトすれば、やはり密度行列が残る。つまりこれらのステップを
合成すると、常に密度行列を密度行列に変換することが保証される。そして線形でもある。
この時点でまったく明らかでないのは、すべてのchannelが実際にワークスペース系と
ガベージ系、そしてユニタリ操作Uの何らかの選択によってこの方法で実装できるということだが、それは真実であり、
レッスンの終わりまでに理由が分かる。完全位相緩和qubit ChannelのStinespring表現の例を示す。
明確にしておくと、ワイヤーはqubitであり、これは通常の制御
NOT gateだ。非常にシンプルだ。入力qubitは上にあり、ゼロ状態に初期化されたワークスペースqubitを導入する。
次に、入力qubitが制御でワークスペースqubitが
ターゲットである制御NOT操作を行い、その後ワークスペースqubitをトレースアウトする。直感的に言えば、
これが完全位相緩和Channelを実装するのは理にかなっている。なぜなら制御NOT gateは上の
qubitの古典状態を下のqubitにコピーすることで、ある種の標準基底測定のように振る舞い、その結果が捨てられるからだ。
しかし計算で確かめることもできるし、もちろんそうするのは良いことだ。直感だけを信用すべきではないから。
直感を信頼しすぎるべきではない。workspace qubitが導入された後の2つのqubitの密度行列表現を書き下すことから始めよう
qubitの順序規約を使っていることに注意してくれ。下のqubitが左側、
上のqubitが右側だ。この密度行列を実際の4x4行列として明示的に
表現できる。画面に示されている通りだ。そしてcontrolled NOTゲートがこの密度行列に与える効果を計算する
つまり、このゲートに対応するユニタリ行列で共役を取る。qubitの順序規約を念頭に置いてだ。これが正しいユニタリ
行列で、結果はここに示してある。実質的にcontrolled NOTゲートは
元の行列の要素を少し並び替えた。今や非ゼロになりうる要素は
四隅にある。後は部分トレースを計算するだけで、行列から直接計算することもできるが、
別の方法として、ディラック記法に変換することもできる。画面に示されているように、そうすると
各項において左のqubitをトレースアウトしたときに何が起きるかを評価するのがかなり簡単になる
その結果、ρの対角成分に対応する項だけが残り、qubitが
位相消去されることがわかる。予想通りだ。いつものように、もし望むなら自分のペースで確認してみてくれ。
これは密度行列や部分トレースを扱う練習として良い
いい例だ。完全位相消去channelを実装する方法はそれだけじゃない。ここに別のStein spring表現がある
このchannelの別の表現だ。この動画では詳細な計算は省くが、立ち止まってじっくり見たい場合のために簡単に示しておく
仕組みは最初のものと似ているが、詳細は
異なる。今回はworkspace qubitにHadamardゲートを適用するところから始める。これでqubitはプラス状態になる
テンソル積を展開すると、画面に示されている行列が得られる。control Zゲートを適用するには
対応するユニタリ行列で共役を取る。その結果、行列にいくつかのマイナス符号が注入される
特に最後の行と最後の列の両方が-1倍される
今回はディラック記法に変換するとかなり煩雑になるので、部分トレースを
直接計算する。2つのqubitのうち最初のqubitをトレースアウトすると、得られるのは2つの対角2×2ブロックの和だ
最終結果は、やはりqubitが位相消去されたということになる。手早かった。こういった計算に
慣れていないなら、時間をかけてゆっくりやってくれ。速さは重要じゃない
この例を締めくくるにあたって、この実装の背後にある非常にシンプルなアイデアについて触れておきたい
先ほど駆け足で見た計算の最後のステップで、それはうまく表現されている。より簡潔に言うと、
与えられたqubitの密度行列とその密度行列をパウリZ行列で共役したものを平均すれば、
それは位相消去と同じことになる。つまり完全位相消去channelは混合ユニタリ
channelになっている。何もしないか、つまり恒等操作を行うか、Zゲートを実行するかのどちらかで、それぞれ
確率1/2だ。知っておいて損はない。まとめると、完全位相消去channelには2種類の
Stein spring表現があり、それが重要なことを教えてくれる。つまりStein spring表現は
一意じゃないということだ。実際、任意のchannelに対して無限に多くの表現が存在する。次にKraus
表現について説明する。これは行列の
積と和によってchannelを表現する便利な公式的方法だ。Kraus表現はCarl Kraussにちなんで名付けられた。彼は物理学者で、
channelの基本的な数学的詳細の多くや、量子情報の一般的な定式化をより広く整理した人物だ。一般に
Kraus表現は、画面に示されている形のchannelの表現だ。特に、
ここではA_0からA_と名付けられた行列の集合があり、正の整数nに対して、
公式に従って任意の入力ρに対するchannelの作用を指定する。簡単に言えば、これらの行列でρを共役にして
これらはこの文脈でKraus行列と呼ばれることが多い。そして結果を足し合わせれば出力が得られる。これらの行列はすべて
同じ次元を持つ必要があり、特に列は入力系の古典状態に対応し、
行は出力系の古典状態に対応しなければならない。その場合、任意の
Kの選択に対してA_K * ρ * A_K†の積を取れば、出力系の古典状態に対応する行と列を持つ正方行列が得られる
したがって、この式が出力系の密度行列を生成することは理にかなっている。しかし、これらのKraus行列を
任意に選んでも有効なchannelが得られるわけではない。ただし、有効なchannelが得られることを保証する
かなりシンプルな条件が行列に存在する。その条件がここに示されている式だ
具体的には、すべてのKの値にわたってA_K† * A_Kの積を足し合わせると
恒等行列が得られなければならない。それは行と列が
入力系の古典状態に対応する恒等行列だ。最初の式で定義される写像が
有効なchannelであるためには、この条件が満たされなければならない。そして実際、すべてのchannelはこの
形の表現を持つことがわかっている。nを十分大きく取れば。ここにKraus
表現のいくつかの例を示す。qubitリセットchannelから始めよう。このchannelのKraus表現は
2つのKraus行列を使うことで得られる。|0⟩⟨0|と|0⟩⟨1|だ。この例ではnは2に等しい
これらの選択を一般式に代入すると、項が2つだけなので和を書き出しやすい
簡略化して括弧内の式がρのトレースであることに気付けば、
qubitリセットchannelが得られることがわかる。これらの行列に対して必要な条件が満たされていることも確認できる。KrausのCR
行列を方程式に代入して評価すればよく、必要な通り恒等行列が得られる。別の例として、
完全位相消去channelを見てみよう。|0⟩⟨0|と|1⟩⟨1|という行列を取るのがうまくいく。和を展開すれば
必要なものが得られることがかなり直接的にわかる。やはり必要な条件は満たされている。
別の方法としては、A_0を√2分の1の恒等行列にして、A_1を
√2分のシグマZにする。評価すると、やはり完全位相消去channelが得られる。この観察に基づいて
このチャンネルについてレッスンの少し前に述べたことで、また必要条件はかなり単純明快だ
役に立つなら演習として確認してみるといい。完全脱分極化
channelを考えてみよう。これはすべての密度行列入力に対して完全混合状態を出力する。このchannelには4つのクロス行列が
必要で、nが3以下のクロス表現を作ることは不可能だ。うまくいく選択肢の一つを示す。
そしてもう一つの選択肢がある。演習は、これらの選択肢がうまくいくことを確認し、必要条件を
満たしているか確認することだ。2番目の代替案は基本的に、qubitを完全に脱分極化すること、つまり言い換えると
4つのパウリ行列（単位行列を含む）のうちの一つをランダムに選んで適用することで
対応するユニタリ操作をqubitに適用することで完全にランダム化することが可能だということだ。したがって完全脱分極化channelは混合
ユニタリchannelのもう一つの例だ。扱う3つのchannel表現の最後はChoy表現だ。Manduin Choyは
行列論などのトピックを研究している数学者で、Choy表現は彼の名前から取られている
1975年に発表した本当に優れた論文に基づいていて、ある意味でこれらすべてをまとめている。channel fの
Choy表現は、慣例的にjfiと表記される単一の行列だ。具体的に入力系が
n個の古典状態を持ち、出力系がm個の古典状態を持つ場合、fのChoy表現は
n×m行のn×m列の正方行列になる。行列の定義を正確に説明する前に、いくつかの
主要な性質について述べたい。それらは、少なくとも表面上は、実際の定義そのものよりも
この表現を動機付ける。まず、Stein spring表現やクロス表現とは異なり、Choy表現は
いわゆる忠実な表現で、各channelがただ一つのものを持つという意味だ。これは非常に重要だ
なぜなら、2つのchannelが同じであるのは、それらのChoy表現が同じである場合に限るからだ。したがって
2つの異なるStein spring表現や2つの異なるクロス表現、あるいはそれぞれ一つずつといった、2つの異なるchannel記述がある場合で
それらが実際に同じchannelかどうかを知りたいなら、Choy表現を計算するだけで
等しいかどうか確認できる。2番目の性質は、Choy表現について、それが妥当なchannelである場合に限り真となる簡単な条件が確認できることだ
その性質はそれほど特別ではない。他の2つの表現についても同じことが言える。しかしそれは良い性質だ
いずれにせよ、後でさらに詳しく議論する。Cho表現についてもう一つ注意すべきことは、
channelを行列で表しているが、この行列は線形写像としてのchannelを直接表すわけではない。実際
Choy表現を、ある状態を表す密度行列と関連付ける方が、
Choy表現を線形写像を記述するものと考えるよりも自然だ。ただし、channelの作用を
Tri表現から比較的単純な式を使って復元することは可能だが、通常の行列
積のように単純ではない。前置きはこれくらいにして、実際の定義に入ろう。系Xから系Yへのchannel phiがあるとし
入力系Xの古典状態集合をSigmaとする。出力系の古典状態集合は参照する必要がないので
定義においてその名前は不要だ。phiのChoy表現は、画面に表示されている式で定義される
入力系のすべての古典状態AとBにわたる和があり、
k a bra bとchannel phiをk a bra bに適用したものとのテンソル積の和だ
この表現は式で定義されており、この式の考え方にはいくつかある。しかし議論する前に
chart表現は少し異なる形で定義されることがあり、2つのテンソル因子の順序が逆になっている、つまり
phi of k a braが第2テンソル因子ではなく第1テンソル因子として現れる場合があることを述べておきたい。しかし2つの異なる定義方法は
この単純な対称性のもとで同等だ。しかしそれが意味するのは、この表現を使うときは
どちらの順序を使っているかを明確にするのが良いということだ。この順序はkcitでの方法であり、
ブロック行列の観点から表現を視覚的に説明するのにも適している。これが採用する方法だ。ブロック行列について
より正確に述べると、古典状態集合Sigmaが0からn-1までの整数からなると仮定すると
ある正整数nに対して、jphiをブロック行列として書くこともできる。これは画面に示されている
言い換えると、phiのChoy表現は、一つのエントリだけが1でそれ以外のエントリがすべて0の各入力行列に
phiを評価して得られる行列で、それらを
自然な方法で行列に並べたものだ。なぜこのような行列を作りたいのか最初は明確でないかもしれないが
非常に有用であることがわかる。注意すべき一つのことは、AとBが両方とも0からn-1のすべての整数にわたる場合
k a bra bという行列の集合がすべてのn×n行列の空間の基底をなすということだ。したがって
この行列があれば、線形性によって任意のn×n行列にphiが何をするかを確実に決定できる
具体的には、ブロックの適切な線形結合を取ることで。したがって行列jphiは実際に
phiを線形写像として一意に決定する。channelのChoy表現を考えるもう一つの方法は
正規化されたとき、つまり
入力系の古典状態の数（これを小文字nで表す）で割ると、密度行列を表す状態であるということだ。これは常に
密度行列を与え、それはしばしばchannelのChoy状態と呼ばれる。これがより詳細にどのように機能するかを見てみよう
まず、入力系の2つの同一のコピーがあると想像し、量子状態ベクトルsを考える
画面に表示されているこれは、この2つの同一系のペアのいわゆる最大エンタングル状態を表している
例えばSigmaが2値アルファベットなら、これはf+状態だが、任意の
Sigmaの選択に対して類似的に定義された状態を考えることができ、得られるのは高度にエンタングルした状態で、実際これは
この系の選択のもとで得られる最大のエンタングル状態だ。状態の密度行列表現を得るには、通常通り状態ベクトルにその共役転置を掛け
これがその結果だ。そして最終的に、nで割ったchannelのChoy表現を考えると、それが
channel phiを2番目の系に適用することで得られる状態であることがわかる。図の形でいうと
これがその様子だ。最大エンタングル状態sにある系Xの2つのコピーがある。channel fが
2番目の系（図の上側の系）に適用され、結果として得られる状態がphiのChoy状態だ。もちろん通常は
2つの異なる系に同じ名前を付けない。2つの異なるものに同じ名前を付けるのは一般的に有益でないが、ここでは意味をなす
この場合、Choy表現との関連を示すために、このChoy表現の見方からすぐに導き出せる
いくつかの含意がある。一つ目は、Choy状態が密度行列であるため、fが
有効なchannelだとすると、fiのChoy表現は正半定値でなければならないということだ。密度行列は
channelに課される要件、つまりchannelは常に密度行列を密度行列に変換するという要件を
思い出してほしい。これはその特別なケースの一つだ。二つ目の含意は、任意のchannel fiのChoy状態を取って
出力系yを捨てると、入力系X上の完全混合状態が残るということだ。それは
channelを系に適用してから結果の系を捨てることは、元の系をそのまま捨てることと等価だからだ。
もし最大エンタングル状態に対してそれを行うと、残る密度行列は
nで割った単位行列、つまり系Xの完全混合状態になる。より
数学的に言えば、任意のchannelに出力系のトレースを合成すると入力系のトレースに
等しくなるということだ。それはchannelが線形写像であり、常に密度行列を
密度行列に変換するという事実から、トレースを保存しなければならないからだ。この等式が得られたら分母のnを
両辺から消して少しすっきりした条件が得られる。言葉で言えば、channelのChoy表現の出力系に
部分トレースを行うと入力系上の単位行列が得られなければならない。まとめると、channelのChoy
表現は常に正半定値であり、出力系をトレースアウトすると必ず
入力系上の単位行列が残る。実はこれらは必要条件であるだけでなく
十分条件でもあることがわかる。つまり、Iが何らかの任意の線形写像であり、これら二つの条件が両方成り立てば
fiは実際に有効なchannelでなければならない。なぜそうなるかはこのレッスンの終わりまでにわかるだろう。
いくつかの例を見てみよう。まず完全デファジングchannelから始める。Choy表現を計算するには
公式を評価するだけだ。完全デファジングchannelはaがBに等しいとき|a⟩⟨B|をそのままにし、それ以外は出力が
ゼロになる。なので和の中で残る項はaがBに等しい場合で、結果は
ダイラック記法を使ってスクリーン上に表示される。ブロック行列として見ることもできる。デルタは対角成分をそのままにし、非
対角成分をゼロにする。なので左上と右下の角に1を持ち、それ以外の
成分がゼロの行列が残る。これは最初の表現と一致する。別の例として、完全脱分極channelを考えてみよう。再び
公式を書き下すことから始められる。前の例と同様に、aがBに等しくないとき
和への寄与はない。今回はaがBに等しいとき完全混合状態が得られ、それを簡略化すると
1/2かける2x2単位行列のテンソル積で、これは1/2かける4x4
単位行列になる。ブロック行列の観点からも考えられるが、当然同じ結果になる。最後の例として
単一qubitのidentity channelを考えよう。これは簡単だ。公式はこうで、
identity channelは何もしない。結果はf+状態に関連した密度行列の2倍として考えられる。これは
このchannelのChoy状態について考えることで期待されるものと一致する。ブロック行列として見るとこうなる。特に注目すべきはChoy
identity channelの表現は単位行列ではなく、この行列だということだ。これで三つの異なる
数学的なchannel表現方法を見てきた。すなわちStein spring表現、Kraus表現、そしてChoy
表現だ。また、channelの定義として、channelは常に密度行列を密度行列に変換する線形写像であり
channelが複合系の一部にのみ適用される場合もそうだということも知っている。非常に自然で非常に重要な
問いはこの時点でこれらが全て等価だとどうやって分かるか、ということだ。例えば、これらの表現の
どれかで記述された写像が実際に有効なchannelであるとどうやって分かるか、そしてchannelが漏れていないかどうかはどうやって分かるか。
レッスンの残りでは、これら全てを数学的に推論する方法を説明する。これらの等価性を認めて、どうやって推論できるか
興味がなければ、動画の残りはスキップして構わない。でも個人的にはこの議論はかなり
スマートで、量子情報の理論で時々出てくる特定のスタイルの数学的証明の良い例だと思う。
全ての詳細を説明するわけではなく、一部はあなたに任せるか、このレッスンの文書コンテンツで全て詳細に書いてある。
でもどう全部うまくいくかのかなり明確な絵を提示したいと思う。やりたいことは
一連の文の等価性を証明することで、その方法は含意のサイクルを設定することだ。具体的には
channelの定義、つまり常に密度行列を密度行列に変換する線形写像から始める。
この定義からこのchannelのChoy表現は二つの条件を満たさなければならないと推論できる。
そしてそれは既にやった。これはchannelのChoy状態の文脈で議論された。次に定義のことは全て忘れて
Choy表現から作業を進める。Choy表現に関する二つの条件が与えられると、写像fiのKraus表現が存在しなければならないと結論付ける。
次に同様のことをする。Choy表現のことは忘れて
任意のKraus表現から作業を進め、写像fiにStein spring表現が存在しなければならないと推論できる。ちなみにこれらの
議論はある意味機械的で、特定のchannelについて矢印に従って実際に変換を実行することができる。
最後の含意は、写像fiにStein spring表現があれば
その写像は実際に有効なchannelでなければならないと推論することだ。これも既にやった。今度はStein spring
表現の文脈でだ。これら四つの含意を全て合わせると、これら四つのものが全て等価であることが明らかになる。どれか一つから始めて
含意を推移的に辿ることで他のどれかにたどり着けるからだ。最初の含意から始める。
channel fiがある、つまり常に密度行列を密度行列に変換する線形写像があるとすると、Cho
表現は先ほど特定した二つの条件、つまり正半定値であること
と出力系をトレースアウトすると入力系上の単位行列が得られることを満たす。さっき述べたように
この含意はChoy状態の文脈で既にカバーしている。特にchannelのChoy表現をnで割ると、入力系の
古典状態の数が密度行列になり、しかもその状態の入力
系Xの縮約状態は完全混合状態、つまりnで割った単位行列になる。分母を消すと二つの
条件が得られる。なのでこの含意はかなり素早く簡単で、既にカバーしているからだ。
では、第二の含意を見ていこう。今回はChoiの写像の表現から始める。これは
二つの要件を満たすと仮定したものだ。目標は、この写像のKraus表現を導出することで、
先ほど話した要件を満たすものにする。この含意はある意味かなり機械的だ。少し
線形代数が必要になって、主に行列とベクトルをかなり巧みに
操作することになる。まずChoi表現が半正定値であるという仮定から始まる。これが我々が仮定している二つの要件の一つ目だ。
半正定値行列という概念は量子情報において根本的に重要で、密度
行列の文脈だけではない。ここでも絶対に欠かせない。これなしではうまく機能しない。特に、
J(fi)が半正定値であるという仮定により、画面に示された形式で表現できる。何らかの
ベクトルs0からSN-1と、正の整数nを選ぶことで。なお、これらは
必ずしも単位ベクトルではないことに注意。このような表現を得る一つの方法は、正の
半定値行列のスペクトル定理からで、前の授業で議論した。ここでは固有値がスペクトル
分解のときのように明示的に現れていないが、半正定値行列の固有値は常に非負の実数であることを思い出してほしい。また、
これらのベクトルs0からSN-1を単位ベクトルとは要求していない。だから固有値の平方根を取って
スペクトル分解から得られる単位固有ベクトルに掛け合わせることで、これらの
ベクトルs0からSN-1を得る。実はこの証明においてこれらのベクトルが直交である必要はない。
スペクトル分解からはそれが得られるが、ここでは使わない。もしスペクトル定理によらない別のJ(fi)の表現があったとしても、
それで全く構わない。次に、画面に示されているように各ベクトルを分解する。
これは、これらのベクトルがXYという対の系の量子状態ベクトルであって、
X系に対して標準基底測定を行う場合と同じやり方だ。ただし、ここでは何も測定していない。単にこの形式でベクトルを書いているだけで、
これは常に可能だ。さあ、ここがトリックだ。Kraus行列a0からaN-1を定義する。s0からSN-1の前についているket aを
取り外して、それをbra aに反転させて、画面の式に示されているように
右辺に付け加えることで定義する。一つの見方としては、
これらのベクトルを折り畳んで行列を形成しているということだ。AKの列を縦に積み重ねると
sに戻る。つまりこれらの行列は対応するベクトルと全く同じ要素を持っているが、
行列になるよう要素を並び替えただけだ。またこれらの行列をDirac記法で純粋に記号的に考えることもできる。
ここに書かれているように。この時点で、明らかな疑問が生じる。なぜこれがうまくいくのか？まあ、あまり深く考えず
うまくいくことを検証しよう。そのために、これらの行列をKraus行列として扱って定義される新しい写像を定義しよう。
次にこの新しい写像のChoi表現を計算すると、
最初に出発した写像FのChoi表現と等しいことがわかる。
Choi表現は忠実なので、二つの写像は実際に等しいということになる。このビデオでは代数の部分は省く。
自分で検証してほしい。かなり機械的だし、良い練習になる。必要なものは全て
画面に表示されている。二つのボックスの第二の条件についてはまだ何も言っていないが、
それらは等価であることがわかっている。それを確認する一つの方法は、画面下部に表示されている式を検証することだ。
ここでTという文字は行列の転置を表していて、ket a bra bをket b bra aに変換する
線形写像と考えることもできる。これは式を成立させるために必要なものだ。まとめると、
この含意には確かにある程度の代数が必要だが、言った通り全て機械的だ。
基本的に指標の体操と呼ぶ人もいる種類のものだ。でもやり通して頭で消化すると、
Choi表現とKraus表現の関係についてより深い理解が得られるかもしれない。第三の含意は、
通常の条件が成立するKraus表現からStinespring表現へと移ることを可能にする。これは前の含意と
精神的にかなり似ている。機械的で、純粋に代数的な項で見て検証できるという意味で。
アイデアは実はかなりシンプルだ。Kraus行列を取って、
画面に示されているように積み重ねることで、より大きな行列の一部を形成する。完成すると、これがStinespring表現のユニタリ行列Uを与える。
ユニタリ行列は正方行列でなければならないので、必要なだけ残りの
列を埋める必要があるが、ユニタリ行列が得られる限り何であっても
実際には問題ない。Uがユニタリであるという懸念を一旦脇に置いて、この行列Uが定義する
線形写像だけに注目すると、その写像はStinespring表現から得られる
元のKraus表現で定義されたfi と等しいことがわかる。それもこのビデオでは証明しない。
詳細はこの授業の文章コンテンツにあるが、自分で時間を取って解いてもいい。ただし
このシリーズでいつものように、ket順序規約を使って図を解釈していることを念頭に置いてほしい。wとGは
式の左辺のテンソル因子に対応する。ところで、もし
やり通すと、左辺のテンソル因子としてket 0 bra 0があるため、
検証が必要な式に対してUの唯一の関連する部分はKraus行列で与えられる部分だとわかる。だからUの列を
ユニタリになるように埋める限り問題ないが、もちろんこれにはa0からaN-1を積み重ねた際に形成される列が
正規直交である必要がある。ここでKraus表現に課す条件が重要になってくる。
実際、それは列が正規直交であることと完全に等価だ。この結論を導くために必要な数学的関係は
画面下部に示されている。一時停止して確認するか、
詳細については文章コンテンツを参照してほしい。要するに、この含意と前の含意の両方で起きていることは、
同じ数学的操作を異なるが等価な方法で記述しているということだ。
その全ての核心は本質的に行列の積だ。第四の最後の含意は、ある写像のStinespring表現があれば
その写像は実際に有効なチャネルでなければならないことを確立する。先ほど示したように、
この含意はStinespring表現を議論したときに既に取り上げた。まとめると、
少し異なる言い方をすれば、初期化されたワークスペース系を導入することは有効なチャネルだ。固定された
密度行列を与えられた密度行列にテンソル積すると常に密度行列が得られ、テンソル積の双線形性により
線形写像になる。ユニタリ操作は先ほど授業で議論したように常に有効なチャネルだ。系をトレースアウトすることは有効なチャネルだ。部分トレースは
常に密度行列を密度行列に変換する線形写像だからだ。そして最後に、
チャネルの合成は常にチャネルになる。これは非常にシンプルだが、それ自体として観察する価値は十分にある。そして
今カバーした四つの含意によって、三つのチャネル表現の等価性と
チャネルの元々の定義を確立した。特に、チャネルの定義から始めて、その定義がChoi
表現が必然的に二つの基本条件を満たすことを意味することを見た。次に、それらの条件がKraus表現を見つけることを可能にし、さらに
Stinespring表現を見つけることを可能にすることを見た。最後に、Stinespring表現の存在が実際に
有効なチャネルを持っていることを明らかにすることを見た。もちろん技術的な詳細はあるし、特に
初めて見るときは必ずしも簡単ではない。しかし興味深く注目すべきことは、これらの含意が実際に
物事をできる限り簡単にするように設定されているということだ。数学において、楽な道を取ることに恥を感じる必要は全くない。
例えば、全てのチャネルがStinespring表現やKraus表現を持つことは全く自明ではない。
しかし、全てのチャネルのChoi表現が我々が関連付けた二つの条件を満たすことは比較的容易に結論付けられる。
そして、それによって他の二つの表現へと至るより代数的な道筋を辿ることができる。同様に、
Stinespring表現から定義に戻る最後の含意も比較的わかりやすい。そして
Choi表現から、必要な条件が満たされている限り、チャネルのみが得られて他の写像は得られないと結論付けられる。
そして先ほど仄めかしたように、これらの含意を論じる方法は十分に機械的で、表現間を容易に変換できる。
授業で以前取り上げたいくつかの例に戻ると、表現間を変換することが実際に可能で、
時にはかなり簡単かつ直接的にできることがわかる。これでこの
授業は終わりだ。全てチャネルについてだった。チャネルとは何かを話し、基本的な例をいくつか見た。チャネルを表現できる三つの方法を議論し、
これらの表現の等価性を確立する技術的な詳細にも踏み込んだ。
次の授業は量子情報の一般的な定式化における測定についてだ。ぜひ参加してほしい。それまでさようなら。